Scranton Pennsylvania
a city very American very Irish American
[Music]
there is this counted a quarter of its
population as Irish descendant including
the Scranton boy who made the big stage
somebody in power who's Irish who's very
proud of where he came from even though
maybe not being born in Ireland is a
very cool thing it is such an amazing
thing to be Irish and the president he
seems proud oh yes very proud
a young baseball loving Joe Biden lived
at this Scranton house until he was 10
years old it was the home of his
grandfather Ambrose Finnegan he was told
many times the story of his Irish Roots
it's a story he's clearly never
forgotten
my grandfather Ambrose Finnegan every
time I walk out of his house he'd say
Joey remember the best drop of blood in
his Irish
Joe Biden themed the White House Irish
for Saint Patrick's Day there's a
president whose ancestors crossed the
Atlantic in the 19th century the
Finnegans of County louth and the
bluitts of County Mayo
behind a green door in Washington we
heard of the Biden contribution
to peace in Northern Ireland Stella
O'Leary is the president's appointee to
the international fund he's a hero as a
Senator Joe Biden helps set up the fund
to promote peaceful coexistence in
Northern Ireland that was an existence
starting from 1986 so it also formed the
foundation of the peace agreement so
it's been a long time and Joe Biden was
in there from the start five six
this President knows the place and the
process that's long taken one step
forward and two steps back
this week he'll celebrate the progress
he helped to promote
James Matthews Sky News in Scranton
Pennsylvania